For as long as there have been poor and
rich people have devised clever ways to
redistribute wealth.
Whether it be taxes,
political manifestos or buy more
barbaric means,
but you may still be left unsatisfied
with the current system wondering where
is your cut you after all are smarter
than the average person yet stuck with
an average bank account.
Today we're going to change that.
We're cutting corners and making money
moves because there is a business plan
that can create massive amounts of
wealth for you with minimal effort
though you may have to leave a few
ethics at the door.
I'm talking of course about the pyramid
scheme.
Before we begin,
you should know what you're getting
yourself into.
A pyramid scheme is a business blend
where recruits buy in to the scheme by
paying people above them and then can
recruit people below them and profit
from what those new people pay in.
One of the most popular variants of the
scheme is the airplane game and it works
like this.
You buy in for $1,500
under someone else as a passenger and
every time the flight gets filled
everyone gets promoted.
Passenger to crew crew to copilot and
copilot to pilot until after a few full
flights.
You become the pilot and once you have a
full flight,
you finally exit by getting paid $12,000
eight times your original investment.
It sounds easy enough,
but there's a very serious problem.
This traditional type of pyramid scheme
involving direct buy-ins is illegal in
most modern countries because the
business plan is built on the idea of an
exponential chain of people,
which is unsustainable living the
majority of the people at the bottom
having lost money,
which is a bummer if you have dreams of
Egyptian polygons,
but to the less scrupulous among you
fear not for where there's a way to make
money hand over fist.
There's usually a legal way to do that
and that holds true for pyramid schemes.
So here are the six steps to creating a
perfectly legal pyramid scheme.
Step one,
find a product.
Don't worry.
It doesn't have to be that good of a
product or competitive in the open
market because you're not really going
to be selling this product in the
traditional sense.
A product to a pyramid scheme is more
like poker chips to a casino there.
The legal way you make money change
hands.
Imagine we take the structure of a
pyramid scheme and instead of the buy
end being cash,
you make it a product.
This way you can say you're providing a
good or service to your customers even
if your customers are just the people
working for you.
Now,
there is one thing to think about when
choosing a product in order to pay every
person along the chain of the pyramid
enough.
It's important that you have high profit
margins and typical wholesale margins
just aren't going to cut it,
so triple the price of your product and
call it premium.
Again,
don't worry about demand.
Your employees will be purchasing your
overpriced products hoping to get rich,
not to save money.
Step two,
make a payout structure.
You might think this should be
straightforward,
but whatever you do,
do not make this simple or
understandable.
You should have two goals in mind when
doing this.
One,
keep most of the profits going to the
top while making people feel like the
bottom has a chance of making it because
poor people need hope to.
And secondly,
you need a constant stream of new
recruits joining and buying in,
so make sure the path to wealth is paved
by constantly recruiting other people,
not actually selling the product.
Besides your best customers are people
who work for you anyways.
You've made a good payout structure at
when people feel like making it is
always a year or two away and they felt
like that for five years.
That completes the fundamentals.
You've got your business plan up and
running and now you need some
underlings.
This is where we get to marketing.
Selling your pyramid scheme is all about
messaging,
so focus on what your recruits one money
and time freedom,
which brings us to step three,
so a financial fantasy.
Here's some examples of what that might
look like.
If you could close your eyes and imagine
your dream lifestyle,
your ideal combination of work and play.
Choose the largest industry in the world
for the biggest opportunity.
Imagine being part of a company that is
created a life changing financial
freedom for people just like it.
Hold on.
A golf course,
half a million dollars,
$110,000
a hundred thousand dollars a few
thousand,
a minimum of 10,000
but the freedom of owning an online
automated business that's priceless.
And bragging about it on the Internet,
even more priceless.
But sometimes this fantasy can backfire
if people don't fully believe in.
If that happens,
this top recruiter says you can still
close them by pointing out the problems
in their lives and using it against
them.
One of the biggest things that I teach
is stack up enough problems that they
have in their personal life.
And when you compare it to the money,
I say they're in.
Well,
if you found out that right now that
relationship is on the rocks,
we were like,
Dang,
dude.
Yeah,
your relationship,
right?
I mean,
are you okay with that?
What's gonna happen with the kids?
Like who's going to get,
who have you thought about that?
So like Joe [inaudible] joint custody.
Is it going to be like,
yeah,
she got to take half and all of a sudden
they're like,
holy crap,
okay,
yeah,
I need a fix this thing.
Now all of a sudden I'm like,
okay,
great.
Here's the solution.
All problems can be exploited including
marital struggles and family problems
and all problems can be solved by
joining as a final part of this vision
for the fantasy life till you recruits,
they aren't getting hired.
They're starting their own company.
You should call them independent
business owners for a couple of reasons.
First,
it minimizes your legal liability if
they aren't full employees.
Second,
if you're going to build a scam off
hope,
there's no better source than the
American dream of owning your own
business.
Now it's time to start thinking about
audience.
You don't want to try to appeal to
everyone,
otherwise you will appeal to no one.
So you have to think about who you want
to target with your message,
which brings us to step four,
the three key groups,
group one,
family and friends.
Biggie smalls once said,
keep your family and business completely
separated.
But Steve Jobs said,
think different.
So while everyone else is following
common sense advice,
you will make a family business and
business and family like someone who
can't help but shoe horn in politics.
They every single conversation you want
to teach your followers that all
conversations can be turned into sales
pitches group to young people.
Nobody is more gullible and sure of
themselves than an 18 to 22 year old.
So get them while they're hot,
naive and young group three poor people,
whatever you do,
don't waste money targeting big fish.
Rich people don't join pyramid schemes.
They start them.
So instead you want to think differently
and go for the poorest you can find.
You'd be shocked with hardworking people
can scrape together if you tell them
success is only a purchase away.
Immigrant families,
poor areas of town or going overseas to
find entire populations of poor people
are all great options as this recruiter
will show.
There really is no such thing as not
having enough money.
Nobody never doesn't have the money to
go to the same job for emergency
purchasing operation.
Look,
I know it's your first time and by this
point you may feel a little sick about
all this exploitation and there's no
shame in that.
Queasiness is just ethics leaving the
body.
But don't worry,
after your fifth time delivering empty
promises to the hopeful eyes of a single
mother of two,
you really don't feel anything anymore.
And so you know,
many of your business counterparts have
already achieved success targeting
Hispanics.
So make sure you're not late to the
party though.
And don't forget to utilize technology
as you do.
So with Google ads,
you can target the bottom 50% of
society.
Choose your target demographic,
lower that add rate,
and away you go.
So you've got your fundamentals,
you've got your marketing and recruiting
done,
you've got your Google ads running,
but soon your workers may get burnt out.
And to extend their mileage.
It's important to learn how to manage
discontent workers.
This is a vital part of any company,
but especially one where your employees
are doing all the recruiting and buying.
And most of them aren't making any
money.
Step five,
the training attempt failure event loop.
The way to keep your independent
business owners committed isn't to make
them happy,
but rather keep them thinking success is
right around the corner.
You can do this by first innercising
that proper training takes time.
You'll tell them that learning to be an
effective leader is a process and takes
practice.
This is followed by an attempt by them
to recruit and sell with minimal
results.
They don't pay much.
They will get down on themselves for
their failure at which point you need to
make sure to step in and throw a massive
pump up event or meeting.
It's imperative that each of these
meetings,
do you have a couple examples of people
who have achieved monetary success with
your scheme because this will signal to
everyone else that they can make it.
Prop up those winners on stage and let
the survivorship bias do the talking.
That was awesome.
Anybody can do it should be your
message.
In reality.
Of course,
studies of over 350 of your competitors
have found that 99.6%
of recruits lose money.
But we don't have to tell them that.
Just keep focusing on the winning.
We're going to,
which so much you may even get tired of
winning.
I just say,
please,
it's two bucks winning.
We can't take it anymore.
And unfortunately,
some people may get tired of winning and
if that happens,
it's time to move to step six.
Cut off the bad apples.
Legal pyramid schemes eventually get a
reputation because they all resemble one
another.
And no matter how much you convince
people that you're different,
you will get a bad reputation in the
world at large,
which can in turn discourage your
recruits.
The way to get around this is not by
denying the bad opinions are out there
instead,
except misdirect and discredit them.
In the past,
people want stock.
The earth was flat,
seems pretty ridiculous,
right?
At the time,
people didn't know any differently.
The same can be said for the direct
selling and multilevel marketing
industry.
So when comparing legitimate direct
selling companies to a pyramid scheme or
any type of scam will seem as ridiculous
as the earth being flat.
You've done a good job when you don't
have to look over your workers shoulders
you've taught them to monitor for hate
themselves and they will go out of their
own way to avoid negative opinions about
your company all on their own.
Once you have these six steps handled,
you will at last be a successful illegal
pyramid scheme,
controlling millions of workers,
paying pennies on the dollar for worth
this products you sell back to your
workers at triple the price workers who,
well trying to make their own fortune
don't realize they're busy building
doors off nothing but hope alone.
You have designed a wealth
redistribution system of such hubris
that Marx himself ought to be envious
except your taking from the mediocre and
giving to those who truly deserve it.
You,
you who have sacrificed everything,
ethics and all for this dream,
this dream of being successful,
of having it all.
And finally you can taste it.
Ah,
ah,
oh,
oh got a little carried away there.
I've got a few more things to say at the
end of this video and also a word from
our president.
But first we have to talk about today's
sponsor skillshare.
Do you like learning things?
I think you do.
I do too.
And skillshare is a great place to do
that.
It's got thousands of classes and
tutorials from experts to help you learn
things.
Things like animation,
things like editing,
things like photography.
But mostly for me,
I liked the editing part but um,
pretty much you can find whatever you
want.
If you can think of it.
They probably have it even stuff from
people like Chris Cause that in a
nutshell,
I think that's how you say his name.
Um,
they did a great class on breaking down
their animation style.
It's really cool.
So go check them out.
Their annual subscription is less than
$10 a month and if you use Promo code
coffee break link below the first 500
people,
we'll get two months free.
So that's it.
Skillshare,
click the link below first 500 people
two months free.
Okay,
so back to pyramid schemes real quick
before you go,
pause,
pause.
I'm at the end of editing this video.
You probably could.
Um,
but I realized
I didn't say explicitly that this is
sarcastic or kind of sad tire.
I know I probably shouldn't have to say
that because it's rather obvious but um,
I don't know if 2019 we'll have sarcasm
anymore.
So yes,
yes,
it is sad to her.
Don't do that.
Don't start a pyramid scheme.
I just wanted to be explicit about it so
no one could misunderstand me.
Um,
I want to just point you towards some
amazing resources that I found really
useful while doing research and creating
this video.
Originally I was going to do it a very
serious look at,
um,
you know,
multilevel marketing,
that sort of thing and I found super
useful the following three resources for
maybe a first,
the dream podcast.
Go check it out.
It's pretty new,
incredible deep dive research if you
like,
kind of getting into the nitty gritty.
That's what those people do.
Also Robert Fitts Patrick,
he's an mlm experts,
been working on it more than 15 years.
Um,
he let me interview him.
He's been a great resource throughout
this,
so I thank him,
uh,
Christine Richards,
Richard,
uh,
of Orion research.
She also let me kind of talk to her for
awhile.
She's also an expert on mlms.
So go check out her research and what
she's done as well as she had a great
interview on quotes,
the Raven.
And then finally Dr.
John Taylor.
He was one of the main sources that I
cited here of,
from the FTC government where he tracked
how often people succeed in these type
of like legal pyramid schemes.
He is an incredible resource as well.
And now I just want to,
I just want to leave you with this
little gym that I found,
um,
from our president.
If you're in America,
ladies and gentlemen,
Americans need a new plan.
The trump network wants to give millions
of people renewed hope.
Let's get out of this recession right
now with cutting edge health and
wellness formulas and a system where you
can develop your own financial
independence.
The trump network offers people the
opportunity to achieve their American
dream.
I'm still looking for dreams.
I'm doing damn well in life,
but I'm still looking for the dream.